ja natürlich liegt daran dass ich so bin
wie gott oh mein gott ich hab geworden
ich habe gewonnen ich habe geworden ich
habe geworden und mein gott ich habe
noch nie gewonnen
neun leute was geht
wir spielen heute wieder eine runde
handel games auf die heiß und ich werde
mich jetzt darum kümmern dass diese
runde wo möglich wenn es geht wieso
hatte in der ich verstehe es nicht warum
aber mir ein paar leute keinen skin paar
leute haben es genährten ruht auf oder
keine ahnung oder es ist einfach ein
skin ich weiß es nicht
und zwar spielern wäre eine runde ist
dass dieser oyo ich dachte schon ich
bring dir eine runde zwei war games
einfach aus dem grund weil ich gerade
ein bisschen bock drauf habe und meine
face cam ist stinkig weiß nicht warum
ich frage mich das erste mal was das
soll ich werde wahrscheinlich einfach
nochmal bald eine neue kaufen also eine
andere kamera
damit das ganze besser funktioniert ihr
seht auch schon ich bin ein bisschen
weiter weg vom mikrofon weil er immer
meinte guck mal ein mikrofon das sieht
auch vor lecker aus ist das ja immer auf
das war wirklich gut
nils niki westermann ein spaß bin
einfach nur gut drauf und wir spielen
eine runde
survival games bzw hunger games mich
berichtigen daher immer leute den
kommentaren
ist mir eigentlich der aber scheißegal
wie das heißt ich nenne es hunger games
welche mit spielen wir dann hauling
mount der mir noch nie gespielt aber
irgendwie survival games einseitigkeit
auch im kino lief jetzt habe ich für 1
geboten was ist das denn überhaupt bauen
will also das habe ich auch noch nicht
gespielt ja gut das ist ja das geht dann
ja noch gut ich hoffe ihr freut euch
dass eine weitere unter hunger games
kommt und zwar ist heute der dreißigste
dritte wir haben samstag der tag nach
karfreitag irgendwann nachmittags glaube
ich wenn ich jetzt weiß wann ich die
hochladen sache ist nur dass der makler
auf meinen tisch aber indirekt auch
richtig
sache ist die dass simon immer noch
nicht online ist also ich wollte heute
ist gerade der 29 und ist gerade 18 uhr
allerdings kommt diese folge es am 30
gegen nachmittag müsse jetzt alles nicht
verstehen
jedenfalls kamen gestern kein und konnte
frau beziehungsweise keine & company
weil wir beide frauen sind weil wir ich
war da sieht man war allerdings nicht da
das war so das problem das ist ja auch
das problem dass sie man dann einfach
nochmal band bis derb enthält der
belange immer der band immer so bis 15
scheiße das ist genau bundesliga zeit
pendelt bis 3 uhr da manchmal steht auch
nachts um 5 auf das ist ein total crazy
typ denn richtig geschnitten wurden es
geht los
oh mein gott da hat einer an tnt
genommen glaube ich direkt gezündet
das war der fall und es sind gerade drei
leute hinter mir war sollen dort nämlich
einer von den töte du mensch da geht weg
vom meer
einer läuft wenn man hinterher du wenn
du weiter mir hinterher läufst du
natürlich dich aber mit der bloßen hand
okay du hast nicht anders gewollt hätten
gehweg mann die verfolgung nicht alle am
anfang ich hasse das
diese verdammten [ __ ] teste kinder
machen
alexander durchspielen die mit da hab
ich keine lust drauf wenn ich von anfang
an verfolgt werde weil dann leute
blablabla wo man gehe jetzt rein weil
leute mich nur verfolgen wir konkret
aber mein name steht das ist echt
scheiße da bleibe ich hier rein
ach nee hier ist ja das ist ja immer so
blöd das ist ja immer die lobby das ist
allerdings einfach nur ich möchte
irgendwann da genau das steht voll da
kann ich nämlich rein weil ich habe
diesen komischen youtuber vorteil
übrigens fragen ich wette nicht was für
ein camp das ist die wurde mir
mitgebracht ich weiß selber nicht was es
verein ist ich glaube von chicago
redskins red sox oder so die worte
mitgebracht aus amerika von daher muss
ich das auch nicht wissen
eigentlich mag ich auch keine caps aber
naja mal sehen ob das aber nach ausweis
sowie games 1 2 oder 4 alter denn und
verpiss dich
der weg wird man sowohl für wollten wir
den fakt werden noch 30 sekunden
da man ja auch wieder leute 05 minuten
gleich fünf gleich 30 sekunden nur für
wohl nicht aufgepasst 05 minuten heißt
nicht 50 sekunden
seitdem war diese person da hätte ich
mir echt ins gesicht schlagen kippe weil
wir gewinnt 0 fünf minuten hat sich das
in 50 sekunden eine minute hat 60
sekunden das heißt 05 minuten und 30
sekunden
da schreibt mir doch vor allem der
kommentator 17 daumen hoch dass er 17
leute waren genauso blöd und dachten
dann ja noch fünf minuten
50 sekunden sondern die chance an sich
da ist auch schon fünf drin
traurig sowas ganz traurig naja ich hab
gedacht dass ich eigentlich noch in der
happy will's mal wieder aufnehmen
allerdings hab ich mir das letzte
hebbels video angeguckt und da war die
begeisterung nicht so groß weil dieses
spiel und ich bin ja auch eigentlich ein
hauptsächlich minecraft kanal und da
kommt jetzt meine frage an euch die ich
euch allgemein schon stellen wollte
und zwar simcity ist ja vorgestern
gestartet weil das sind auch nur vier
folgen oder fünf folgen oder so die
sache ist allerdings die dass ich jetzt
euch einfach mal fragen wollte die die
hier gerade gegen minecraft den stolz
dass ich das hochladen oder also soll
ich das lieber abbrechen oder soll ich
weiterhin mehr minecraft bringen oder
halt auch so andere spiele
was haltet ihr davon schreibt das bitte
einfach unten in die kommentare und dann
werde ich euch das ein bisschen mit
entscheiden lassen weil mir macht beides
spaß
ich würde allerdings dann auch sim city
dann wieder entfernen beziehungsweise
nicht hochladen
einfach weil viele leute da natürlich
kontra gegeben haben kontrollwahn so ich
hoffe man hier schlägt jetzt keiner bloß
mit der hand einfach weil das ist der
das finde ich total affig einfach nur
aus nicht mehr hinter mir das ist ja der
chor ohne wenn ich hinter mir also bei
dieser map macht das echt eine menge
spaß das habe ich mit simon auch schon
mal hier gespielt war ja nur dann so ein
blöder typ der einfach auf die man mit
der hand drauf gegangen ist das ist dann
natürlich nicht so cool aber das jetzt
erstmal auf uns kann darauf geht das ist
ja schon mal schwierig also mir
hinterher läuft
also schreibt das einfach ich sags mal
so wenn ihr euch entscheiden würde würde
die erst im city nehmen oder einen
minecraft let's play mit gott mit goma
hd die frage war ein video formuliert na
egal schreibt einmal in die kommentare
wenn ihr wollt ich kann noch gar keinen
augenkontakt fliegen in ein nnnn
gutherzigen da keine ahnung wie ich das
jetzt ausdrücken kann ich halte immer
sehr gerne augenkontakt auch mit der
kamera nicht mit mir nicht mit dem
bildschirm sondern auch mit der linse
kann ich allerdings gerade nicht weil
ich mich jetzt ein bisschen eine lampe
jetzt mal war hier eine kiste der mensch
da ich glaube die sind noch immer
unterschiedlich verteilt oder weil
letzte mal waren die krass viele kisten
in diesem wald ist noch fast gar keine
ich muss erstmal ein bisschen bremsen
mensch kommt kein bock ich brauche auf
jeden fall sinken schwarz und habe ich
direkt verklagt da hinten so juli konnte
ich weiß jetzt keinen dienst aber wird
ein heftiges leckeres schwert mensch da
silva selber cooler typ paar leute sind
einfach cool sein cool der hoch hoch
hoch hoch
ach mensch dass diese leute mit angela
gut okay
unter wasser geht die angel glaube ich
nicht mehr unter wasser geht nicht na ja
da war doch was geht wohl doch unter
wasser er hat doch ein schwert
das ist jetzt natürlich blöd das ist
jetzt natürlich gerade sehr blöd
vor allem wenn noch ein halbes herz hat
und er ist direkt hinter mir ich hab
verpackt das könnte man so sagen außer
ich finde jetzt vielleicht noch
irgendeine person die ich hoffe er lässt
ab von mir sieht auch so aus heja mit
glück gehabt heute sind ko runde durch
oder läuft nicht hinterher
relativ okay jetzt werde ich mich kurz
auspressen und danach werde ich aus dem
hinterhalt attackieren
ich hoffe dass ich da noch mehr zu essen
finden irgendwo weil ich brauche etwas
zu fressen sonst habe ich direkt beim
mit einer halben her als dauer da kommt
man nicht weit
ich soll doch gar nicht so zentral jetzt
laufen
ich brauche auf jeden fall was zu essen
ist es scheißegal wie ich noch was zu
essen
egal ob mich ansieht oder nicht geben
man muss mich nur einmal mit der hand
schlagen und wünschen tod oder ich muss
einen kleinen block links runter fallen
hey hier waren kev und dehner und wurde
von dort getötet bei den survival games
die wir gespielt haben
für sachen ich mich immer hier in einer
domain stadt ist doch unglaublich
das lob ich mir doch lob ich mir doch
hier komme ich dir unter unbeschadet
mensch ich muss man ja okay kommt rein
und dann kletter jugendamt richtig weg
ja ja ja er verschwinde lieber so besser
ich habe angst ich muss irgendwie was zu
fressen kriegen man was zu fressen
kriegen mann der fresse kriegt man
und es muss auch hier kann ich die warte
warte warte warte wird nicht nein kann
ich nicht auch verdammt verdammt dark
star mensch darf ich kann noch gar nicht
so lang weil gleichkommt fabio in vier
minuten vergab dann gehe ich gleich eben
ein bisschen risiko 94 minuten kann doch
glaube ich wieder meine facetime ob das
passt dann eigentlich ganz gut hier oben
war sonst meine kiste das weiß ich noch
genau hier stand immer eine heute nicht
jetzt muss ich immer noch in mir rüber
kommen ohne dass ich sterbe das sieht
gut aus
mann mann mann ich muss doch jetzt
irgendwie an was zu fressen kommen
fehler dingsbums mir zu blöd
ich glaube beides ok wo kann ich denn
was zu essen finden
eventuell ist hier ja noch irgendwo eine
kiste versteckt und da es was zu essen
drin oder nicht würde den tier 24
minuten bis zum deathmatch oder gott
mensch da hab ich doch noch ein bisschen
zeit
ich brauche jetzt aber ich habe immer
angst ist diese movie aufnahmestopp und
genau in dem moment stoppt sie h
manchester wieder gestoppt gut ich
brauche jetzt auf jeden fall irgendwas
zu essen
das ist erstmal das einzig wichtige
gerade das sind das
sorin komisch aus da sollte ich mal ein
bisschen mehr in die mitte gehen und da
ein bisschen neues hinschauen denn die
flüssigen wie lava aus arrach die wahl
ob ich ihn auch schon alle über leute
1000 prozent der spanische nation pilz
manager danke aber gut wenn da auf jeden
fall ein pilz liegt dann heißt es ja
dass die hier nicht alles mitgenommen
haben oder dass man solche leute da die
hatten schon alle sachen und haben dann
gedacht supply craig haben die sogar
abgenommen
das sind kleine pfeile blinken manchmal
inventar diese vier die blinkt manchmal
dass noch eine kiste auch leoben noch
was das sonic bittet er etwas drin auch
nicht aber da oben ist eine kuh das
oberlicht wichtig ja toll die kuh die
gibt mir dann vielleicht gibt mir aber
auch nicht drei von diesen sachen kann
ich dann theoretisch in die kiste in den
ofen tun bräuchte ich dann allerdings
alte leute wieder hinterher bot windows
von catania
ich muss einfach nur ein schwein finn
danach bin ich ihn danach bin ich viel
besser als er aus gerüsten halten stein
schwert auch total dumm dass ich gerade
sprinte wenn mir gar keiner
hinterherläuft
ich muss doch irgendwo jetzt ein schwein
oder einen scharfen scharf ja ich es
immer schafft fleisch oder ist ein
großer baum da könnt ihr etwas dahin
ein handy vibriert moment übrigens die
leute wollten ja mal sehen wie mein
bildschirm denn jetzt überhaupt gerissen
ist sieht man das so sieht man auf jeden
fall mal im hintergrund warte ich drei
mal kurz das objektiv so ein bisschen
ich fokussiert das mal ganz anders
nein stau so da sieht man auf jeden fall
hier ist dieser komplette ist drin und
so also das sieht man schon krass
deutlich so jetzt bin ich hier das
schafft also dann bin ich da mal nicht
schaffen und spaß so gut 20 21 haben das
gerade angst habe ich nicht vor noch
gesagt es ist 18 uhr
wahrscheinlich acht uhr sagen oder so
kann es schon mal vorkommen
ich brauche auf jeden fall es irgendeine
kiste oder fleisch oder schweine und ich
dachte eigentlich dass wird so eine
kurze knackige runde wo ich sofort drauf
gehe aber nein ich bin einfach viel zu
gut für diese auch mensch ich liebe
meine ironie und scharf darauf ist
mannschaft hätten
endlich meine rettung wurde nun um mein
gott das könnte sogar ein richtiges fest
essen werden da noch erst mal das rhein
zweifel bin ich vergiftet dass er auch
cool und an das rhein schweifen
ich brauche noch einen ich brauche noch
eine verdammte scheiße keule das heißt
diese eine kuh die da auf dem berg war
die hätte ich echt jetzt kam schert dort
blüht umgangssprache geschossen
jaaaa
ich bin voll mit essen was noch sonst
noch und bin ich die gleiche geblieben
hier sind sogar noch kisten die sind
aber schon geleert da mein freund schon
und dessen lauf ich zu dir zurück bzw
übrigens danke an die leute die mir
geschrieben dass sich reese kaputt
machen kann dass darauf nicht gekommen
weil man kann ja nicht mal allerdings
kaputt machen riet schneider schreib mal
bitte in die kommentare
das soll ein flugzeug glaub ich
darstellen oder eventuell final des
matchs countdown startet wollen mich
verarschen
der standort noch 24 minuten
das sind gerade mal sechs minuten her
ach so weil jetzt nur noch so wenige
sind wir so noch fünf leute sind das so
ich dachte wenn allgemein war schon da
ist er einer bestimmten typ jetzt
übrigens am anfang ist der sache der
neuen schwert okay
hey
losschicken
ja gut solche moment ist einfach geil
warte bin ich eigentlich schade
ich dachte damit wäre huth immer gesagt
denn damit ist ein diamant schwert ja
jetzt dort war tote hose anziehen
er hatte auch nicht jaja sprinter nur
sprinten uhr bringt jetzt auch nichts
hat er meinen kindern
ich glaube doch nicht
ist das ganz blödes alter wieso kann ich
nicht schlagen tiger schattdorf jetzt
werdet ihr fertig gemacht der schießt
sich selbst ab
wir gehen das kann sein dass ich
irgendwie sondern kreativ in die ganze
teile ab wäre ja natürlich liegt daran
dass ich so bin wie gott oh mein gott
ich habe geworden ich habe gewonnen ich
hab geworden ich habe geworden und mein
gott walther ich habe noch nie gewonnen
ja okay doch ich dachte schon als
gradias angel sound gehört dazu fakt
dass
wird auch gerade meine freunde
endlich gewinne ich auch mal die bekam
konsens ja gut freunde mehr spaß gemacht
als kind hat spaß gemacht ich würde
einfach sagen wenn es euch auch spaß
gemacht hat dann gebt einfach einen
daumen hoch das zeigt mir dass euch das
video gefallen hat und schreibt ihnen
kommentare snack was mir auch zeigt dass
immer noch dabei seid und euch ihr euch
diese scheiße geht hier die ich hier
fabriziere ansonsten würde ich erst mal
sagen vielen dank dass ihr zugekauft hat
wartet ich möchte ich auf den street
kommt gucke mir mal bitte an
wer ist das denn können jetzt noch nicht
allerdings bist du mir sympathisch
irgendwie des kunden das zum ersten mal
verstehen
doch jetzt bis auf den tempel darauf hin
dass sind bekommst dann samt mail heißt
eigentlich daumennagel oder debatten es
am samstag dauern
sams und nail ist nicht nagel
na gut wie schon gesagt wird euch
gefallen daumen hoch geben wenn nicht
dann halt nicht und in die kommentare
schreiben
dort dabei sein und dann würde ich sagen
wir sehen uns dann in der nächsten und
pvp hoffentlich wenn simon dann kommt
und bis dahin euch erstmal einen
wunderschönen tag grüßt eure familie von
mir und tschüss